et notre tour de france nous conduit ce
soir à pau où françois bayrou joue gros
le président du modem qui pensaient
s'imposer facilement est en situation
délicate face à la candidate socialiste
caroline le chanteur guys and dolls
ils sont bien loin les grands meetings
de la présidentielle normalement c'est
aux gens de l'office de faire signer un
contrat
aujourd'hui françois bayrou organise des
goûters de campagne dans les cité
paloise et ce n'est plus la foule des
grands jours parler tout enfant du pays
le fondateur du modem se voyait déjà en
haut de la fiche
mais les critiques fusent ses
adversaires lui reprochent de vouloir se
servir de faux comme d'une vitrine les
sondages l'annoncent devancé de quelques
points par la nuit chez moi c'est
toujours sûr que cette bataille elle ce
même ray seul contre tous
pourquoi parce que le parti socialiste
et puis l'ump et même nicolas sarkozy
vont tout faire pour que nous ne gagnons
pas on a besoin d'un chapitre nouveau et
ça sera une histoire d'amour mais celle
qui pourrait briser l' histoire d'amour
paloise de françois bayrou c'est elle la
députée socialiste de la première
circonscription la lumière cassure
bonjour déterminée elle mène sa campagne
avec une bonne dose d'ironie
cette proche de françois hollande
affiche ses convictions elle arbore
l'écharpé rouge pour mieux faire barrage
à l' orange du modem n'est certain de
plaisant la saur l'an dernier c'était la
mode de les sharp orange et les
effectivement le sentiment que françois
bayrou est à la nostalgie de 7 ans quant
à yves urieta c'est son écharpe
tricolore qu'il pourrait perdre le maire
sortant est à la traîne dans les
enquêtes d'opinion la campagne
électorale je
dans ma voiture et je conduis ex
fabusien rejetée par la section ps de la
ville
il est soumis par l'ump et ses fantasmes
contre le cumul des mandats ville de pau
doit être gérée par des gens qui en la
passion de la ville qui ont envie de
servir la ville et non pas de se servir
de la ville et je rajoute nous sommes la
seule ville en france où le maire et les
adjoints n'auront aucun cumul de mandats
ce qui n'est pas le cas de mes
adversaires à pau une triangulaire
semble se profiler à l'horizon
ce qui pourrait mettre françois bayrou
en difficulté lui qui pensait il ya
encore quelques mois être couronnés dont
la cité d'henri caire